hello reject nation it is like almost
100 degrees outside and this is the room
with the least amount of ac airflow but
because it's this movie i'm gonna wear
this beanie it's for the video for you
guys this is daredevil director's cut
gonna do a movie reaction to the ben
affleck led film john has never seen
this film i saw the theatrical version
19 years ago needless to say i think i
only really remember
a moment
one or two months like yeah i kind of
remember that it's gonna be pretty much
a brand new movie for me and it's also a
half hour longer than the theatrical cut
and i've heard it's so much better guys
so full-length watch long recycle with
the time code for daredevil we'll be
over at our patreon page cover a whole
bunch of stuff over there as well your
support means a lot thank you super
rejects leave a like if you enjoy this
one and uh thanks the boys at prepper
help us edit this down gonna be doing
more movie reactions so keep a lookout
let's do this
[Music]
they say your whole life flashes before
your eyes when you die
and it's true
even for a blind man
come on trip hit me i'll give you a free
shot
is that anthony soprano i told you i
didn't want you fighting i tried to walk
away like you said but they kept giving
me [ __ ] don't turn
[Laughter]
you think i'd be pulling double overtime
down at the docks i was working for
fallon what are you nuts you don't hit
nothing with books get me you'll be a
doctor a lawyer
not like me foreshadowing you can do
anything if you're not afraid now you
promised me
that's gotta be the theme of this movie
i promise dad
why would it tie out rope around the
moon
[Laughter]
matt lasso's the moon looking from my
dad jack murdock seen him around murdock
he worked here in months i'll beat it
huh
i love that his hair's a little red i
know
oh he got good grades you're gonna need
that report card though
we're close to the docks matt
[Applause]
wow
wow so his senses were like
instantaneously enhanced that's what
happens when you go blind
whoa
[Music]
jesus will save you young matu
talked to the doctor i'm blind
i know i heard you talking in his office
i hear everything
[Laughter]
i'm an adult now dad
i mean doesn't make you automatically
good at that you know
no in this case it does
and acute sense of touch nice hot head
shot
hey
grunkle stan
what's up freak
show up in the exact same way same out
go ahead fight me i dare you yeah
murdock
i dare ya
[Music]
fight
i don't work for you no more fallon
jack you never stopped
better call saul brigade
something that feels borderline dick
tracy-ish about this uh
what's it gonna call it's flashbacks
it's a cane hotter all right
bernard you all right okay
let's fight
oh no
oh boy
this is currently feeling like a
well-made crowd-funded daredevil
absolutely that's a good call
and
[Music]
parents died in alleyway
ouch i would seek justice
one way
or another
i have enjoyed the symmetry of a lot of
the shots the production design does
feel very much like a graphic novel oh
yeah
those sexy ass knees
pop yourself up drown the world out in
rock
anything that happened after that was
entirely consensual
okay
are you aware that perjury is a crime mr
casanova my client is a respectable
member of the community that only makes
her testimonials her testimony
gentlemen that's enough there's
something
i just haven't enjoyed every minute of
it
oh god that's disturbing
this this scene is aged into greater
relevance
not tonight
you got work to do
get to work boy
yes
oh yeah
post schumacher world
yes
i love it
yes
ah we're both horny yeah it's for real
[Music]
what do you want
justice
nice
oh that was great uh-huh that was really
cool solid action dude
[Music]
skateboard
never lose those skills
i do like the gothic flare man
trains are his weakness
you're dead
oh
no
go to hell
diablo
okay
you'll beat me there
wow
[Music]
that light
the end of the tunnel
guess what that's not heaven
this is something a little more badass
you know no i'm going to use that now
jose
oh my god oh nice he's straight up
killed him yeah dude got a train right
over the nuts there is no proof that
your so-called daredevil was involved
nor that he even exists
too cause it's wet all over here
there's no comic book movie like this to
deck look at that
oh yeah
brooding shower shot you know we need
some better clients i'm tired of these
pro bono cases what's your problem with
our clients we have we have good
honorable clients decent people what's
your idea of better to define better
huh what would be a better client
it's in law school how to create a moral
vacuum yeah you can represent people who
aren't all necessarily innocent it's
your best course as i recall yeah well
you don't have them all
i mean i hate to bring it up again but i
spent three thousand dollars on seeing
eye dog i didn't ask you for the dog i
didn't want a dog
ex-wife oh
she
the other jennifer
she's hideous
i don't know if it's a fungus or some
sort of congenital birth defect but as
you're returning in this matter i advise
you
i was just looking for some honey could
you help me out right in front of you
could you be a little bit more specific
what are you blind yeah
i am so sorry that's okay
[Music]
i tell you some people have no
compassion for the handicap
apparently not
where you going get that [ __ ]
compassion
you can start acting pitiful right now i
don't like being followed so don't
wait a second take it easy
i don't like being touched
yeah
why don't you tell me what you do like
we'll start there
is not the time place
it's a fight date usually a question is
blind ability now
sure you're blind okay i'm sure you
don't wanna tell me your name
[Laughter]
this is the best movie
oh yes you're holding back yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
my name's electro nachos
we call him the master that's all i
wanted to know
terrible terrible way to cover up your
abilities
how am i gonna find you you won't
i'll find you
oh yeah
dad i'm looking for an insanely talented
blind man living in hell's kitchen
i think i can narrow that down
out of their bodyguards their first day
on the job
you think that's horrible don't you
because you don't like the physical
stuff i do
good eye acting on that guy i want you
to buy me out
i think you'll find it's a very generous
offer
how's your daughter
great cigar acting in that scene
dante jackson next con from queens
charged with the august 9th murder of
lisa tazio your friendly neighborhood
prostitute
spider-man reference
jackson
cooley holy [ __ ] we're your attorneys oh
here it goes
so
are you edison
hell yeah
i believe you
you do
you do
you got yourself a defense no foggy's
racist that seems who she is press want
a kingpin
so i'll give him a kingpin give me
bullseye
[Music]
bullseye eye
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god how many paper clips did he
have
how deep did they all go
why does he have a paper clip
the [ __ ] the matrix is a system neo
and it was never a bad time to be cool
huh
gross
[Music]
how badass he is even dogs know
ah
i see
come on matt there's nothing over there
let's go it's a mac m-m-o-o-m-m-6
six eight
eight
there i knew it her mother did it nikoi
please go
get me a computer for christmas last
you can still hear her over those
headphones i said
what just straight up murdering he's
just dead now can i get you anything
before we land
more peanuts
ladies
i got a whole other movie
look at this
it's so beautiful
i know
this is my favorite view of the city
when i was a kid
i really wanted you to see this
describe it to me
when we were kicking each other's ass in
the park
i knew you were the one
first time it falls on a surface
just then it's like
it's like i can see again
and i
i just want to
i just want to see you
damn i totally banged this guy
charming
jeez jesus dude oh wow
it's pretty accurate
[Music]
they're instantly soaked
[Laughter]
i have to go
matt
[Laughter]
damn he hasn't been daredevil for like
30 minutes
please don't hurt me
i'm not the bad guy kid i'm not the bad
guy
conflict
how would you
even consider that
you're beating up obviously very
horrible people
that's your whole thing
cool
color i wouldn't know
we can't represent you
why is that
yes why is that mr murdock
because
we only handle clients who are innocent
ouch
you know i've learned one thing in all
my years in this business what's that
nobody's innocent
especially the blind
[Laughter]
it's like that
you want me to take you up there matt
matt
matt
hitting people out of the way
everyone
i could sense how hot she is tonight
but the only reason i got dressed up for
this thing
was that i wanted to look beautiful for
you
i banged her too i bet both
same time let's do this
eiffel tower go back to the party
day what's wrong your name is too stop
russ will take you home saint paul
oh yeah
i'm sorry
how could you just leave
yeah how [ __ ] rude
i have never i wouldn't know i'm the
blind one
uh
here we go
oh there you go this part of new york
looks like downtown l.a
drop something
[Music]
no
way
come on man
with his own weapon
no
damn
[ __ ]
well if i had to point out bullseye i
know
how did you get past my security
[ __ ] you made that good yeah
oh god
you know you've exceeded all my
expectations
you're hired have you ever owned a
handgun mr jackson no sir do you have
any intention of owning a handgun mr
jackson no sir thank you
can't hit nothing with a handgun
but a shotgun now that's a whole
different story shotgun's got bug shot
it's like little thank you that's all
and when you shoot it they kind of spray
out like that so it could just hit
everything in front of it thank you mr
jackson
for your sake
i hope your partner comes back soon
you are a terrible lawyer son
suppressed
[Music]
we killed her daddy watch you upset
that's just how things go
who left the red rose there who killed
lisa tazio aren't they jacks
i want to know what your copy of
everything
it's the key to beating daredevil just
get a pacemaker oh that that's matt's
big contribution to the tazio case which
has uh surprisingly turned out to be
completely useless flip it upside down
what's the date of the murder august 9th
why
maybe you're looking at it flip it
upside down oh what
brilliant
[Music]
did say matt murdock had a martial arts
battle in the park yeah
several children spotted him
this is not a good time
it's about lisa tazio
i remember this the song on the trailers
the director of this movie do music
videos there's so many needle drops in
this movie
[Music]
she's really good at that [ __ ] holy crap
yeah it's convincing well in size no
easy business
[Music]
i still look hot
wait until matt sees me next
it was a hitman named bullseye
i didn't kill your father
liar
gotta have your cool action boys
the flight ability on these people is
insane yeah their legs must be jacked
oh you could have at least dodged that
listen to me
you have to
[Laughter]
take a drink every time he spreads his
arms out that way
oh [ __ ] it went through her hand huh
yeah
nice
why'd you try to catch it cause i'm
bullseye
why'd she try to catch it yeah that's a
great question
because dodged it
oh my god goodness that is probably
super painful good jesus christ high
velocity papercut
[Music]
[Applause]
that is brutal something more brutal
about it did not piercing the shirt yeah
i don't remember eddie
i was literally like nope
no recollection of this
oh she was only a lecturer for like five
minutes
don't worry
there will be a whole movie oh yeah
oh yeah
how the what how do you get there
movie magic
[Laughter]
i don't ask for mercy
people ask me
don't you dare touch the priest
[Music]
how did you not catch that
[Music]
venom i was just gonna say that
goofy physics there
what does it call it for i don't know
what color pearl's doing but i'm weirdly
enjoying
what the hell
that's awesome
biscuits the kingpin
yeah
the whole red rose thing he loves that
[ __ ] it's not my style
my gosh during the red rose thing for
decades no it all makes sense
[Music]
the way they did that was awesome yeah
jesus
so both his daredevil and batman just
straight up murder
yeah
it's in his contract
touch your forehead one last one
[Music]
i would say this is a better schumacher
movie
[Music]
like a reverse bane
good stunt performers in this one
holy crap that is so painful
hmm
why not kill him
i'm not the bad guy
he just threw bull's eye out the window
strapping that one guy to the train
tracks and throwing bullseye to his
death really taught me something
all right
all right
this scene was added back in
you're not [ __ ] jennifer garner
you're just a stand-in for jennifer
garner i know the truth about daredevil
justice is blind huh
if you run that story
i'm finished but i'm a reporter kid it's
what i do
throw your stick at him
kill him
because evil always survives
with the help
like a weird bulldog or something
that plays that character
[Music]
yes
in case he had to remind himself soon
the world will know the truth
that this is a city born of heroes
control z
[Laughter]
chose a princess yeah
[Music]
good thing there doesn't dare to vote
and take on litterers
a guardian devil
a dark knight
killing it
wow
can't wait for the sequel
it's gonna be so good
i can't wait to get everyone back dude
ellen pompeo was in this dang
dude david keith and keith david should
be in a movie together
david david keith the actor who played
matt murdock's father yes yes
and keith david veteran actor and great
voice yeah
they could play brothers they could
biological brothers in a new remake of
twins
well john
while we
i don't know if there's a post-credits
season
while we wait
for the new post-credit scenes then
um
somebody had to
i believe iron man was the one that
really kicked it off
that iron man is definitely the one that
made it like you expected it and if you
don't get one it's weird i don't
remember if they were already doing it
back then maybe it looks like it
no
black it was a lot of black for no
reason what the hell was that about it i
don't know
such a big gap in the credits there
the article exposing matt murdock was
supposed to go there but then they
deleted it
what did you think
about
daredevil oh boy it was a special
experience you know this is a
fascinating movie experience because
it's intermittently
you know way better than i've heard the
theatrical cut of daredevil is i can
also kind of imagine what might have
gotten cut out and what the theatrical
experience might have looked and been
like
because of some of the it felt like it
was sort of like dipping in and out of
something that was pleasurably
cheesy in a way
and you know it had that sort of
early 2000s comic book attitude where
it's like we gotta make cool and punchy
all the time
uh so yeah i mean it's definitely of its
time but i had a good time and and and
what leaves the impression on me right
at this moment is that you know
for an almost 20 year old movie at the
time of recording this you know there's
a fair amount more that holds up than i
expected
true especially in the construction of
the effects and some of the fights
um
there's definitely some really silly
stuff
but uh but not bad not bad
i think from what i've heard over the
years
is what got cut out of the movie was a
lot of lawyer stuff
okay a lot of actual lawyering
so
and and i don't
i on i mean i don't remember like 99 of
this movie
um
the only thing i kind of remembered
was
uh when electro was training
okay besides but i don't remember
thinking like oh she's actually really
good with that stuff that was a that was
a cool scene yeah yeah and she really
it's weird out of everything sandbags
dropping from i have no idea she
must they're stupid rich so she must
have a system of police
stop watches and who knows what else or
maybe there's an alfred style butler are
they specifically designed to stab and
break
are they designed to kick and punch
because i'm like how many sandbags are
you going through yeah practicing with
these sides you gotta get a whole new
set every single time this cannot be the
most practical way to slicing them open
like but they're just still you know get
something else that doesn't just break
open
um
yeah i think so i think it might have
been all the coolio stuff that was cut i
can't imagine i mean i i enjoyed his his
presence here and and weirdly but i feel
like it's not needed i'm like wait how
exactly does this even play into the
main plot
yeah i mean like it's tangential because
of the way that yeah like the the girl
who was murdered the prostitute who he's
being framed for the murder of is
actually the guy who uh
wow killed
or there's actually the
woman wow killed but at the same time
i'm like i feel like there are other
parts of the plot that would have gotten
us there eventually or at least he
interrogates the cop in the car we'd at
least have gotten to wilson fisk
so yeah i wonder if maybe the some of
the
figuring out of
you know who's to blame on matt
murdock's side you know maybe that
played differently in the theatrical cut
or or was plotted slightly differently
because yeah i feel like aside from that
one bit of connective tissue you can
just remove that and nothing really
happens although i did appreciate that
this had kind of a
for the time it was made the portrayal
of like
crime and and how it affects like people
who are down on their luck and how those
people get exploited at the whims of you
know the people who run thing like that
stuff actually checked better than i
expected uh
for a movie like this so
no
sounds like you really liked it a lot i
loved this
movie they even laid down one criticism
so far oh there's i mean there's tons of
cheese and i mean i would say that the
first
maybe half hour 40 minutes or so
uh it was like this is really cool and
fun and like you know the the the
combination of the effects with like the
film stock because it's still shot on
film and everything i i believe
uh you know like it's definitely shot on
film yeah and so like she brings that
nostalgic effect everything's so digital
now yeah and then there's something
about that that makes it feel a bit more
tangible anyway so for the first hour i
was like i can see what people mean that
this is like significantly like nothing
feels that silly for the most part and
then you know it started to
it's weird it's like i appreciate what
they included and that they have all the
lawyering and all that stuff nobody's
credit scene ah
continued but as i was saying you know
sort of towards the middle of the movie
it does start to sort of sag under the
weight of all the stuff that it's doing
and i feel like
the kingpin and bullseye are in a
slightly different movie from everybody
else which i have a sneaking suspicion
probably would have played better in the
theatrical cut but at the expense of
everything else playing worse in the
theatrical cut so like this is a
it's probably true that's a good way to
think about it yeah and so i know what
you're saying yeah because like they get
more real with the crime investigation
and uh yeah like oh he's going into the
the victim's house and they're doing
actual trials and this is all
surprisingly grounded [ __ ] yeah and then
you got like
not quite but almost shoe mockery
villains there like there's like some
parts that were like i'm getting some
two-faced riddler flashbacks here it's
not that qui it's not that quite as big
but it feels like it would
fit more in that universe for the kind
of extended version this is i think
you're you're both your name checks all
right i feel like this is a what would
happen if you spliced the tim burton
batman aesthetic with the schumacher
batman aesthetic because like there is
that sort of even though new york isn't
quite
something there's got a lot of crow in
there too yeah yeah it's got that gothic
sort of thing going on and it's got a
certain height about it which sometimes
helps the cheese and sometimes really
doesn't help the cheese i mean there's
so much stuff in this movie that feels
like a teenager going look how cool this
is it feels like a crowd made
daredevil yeah like this is really well
made these guys could be great
filmmakers yeah give them a real budget
and some real resources see what they
can do
yeah absolutely
because yeah there's a lot of shots that
feel very much like we're looking at a
comic book panel i actually really
thought a lot of the
cinematography other than the
wildly apparent
we gotta really shadow this up because
we're using a lot of cgi yeah other than
the very apparent moments were there and
you know
to be fair this is 2 000
they must have made this in 2002 this
got released in 2003. so there's there's
been a much bigger evolution and visual
effects
since then not to say that's always
great but i think that with what they're
doing here with the amount of
zipping around is the super heroism
that sometimes the the rules of the
anatomy i was like i love move faster
i'm still questioning it though like
do you guys get hurt like regular humans
but you know yes
like superheroes that's like one of the
craziest so you can leap literally tall
buildings in a single valley
so how heightened are we going right now
why is it only that your leaps are that
jacked whereas like you know
that if your muscles are that way under
this reality would stand to reason that
like any punch would just knock
someone's head off you know for some
reason the because the style of it read
as cheesy versus when you're watching
like a hong kong film like a crouching
tiger for example where you're like no
that's the fighting style but they can
still get hurt like humans for some
reason it doesn't this register is like
goofy or versa i don't know why
um
i think it's too it's just the
combination of all that stuff with then
the leather and the rock music and it's
just so much piled on yeah and you do
have this well i think those hong kong
movies strike a more fantastical tone
and where this
strikes like we're a dark gritty like
[ __ ] punk and
yeah yeah but we do leaps and bounds we
get hurt like regular humans and we do a
lot of like it's it's not quite as as
expressionist and stylized as like a a
chinese opera like a
wusha kind of movie but they do a lot of
still those wire effects
that are a little more heightened of
like when people are it makes the most
sense when wilson fisk is throwing
people around because it's supposed to
be like oh wow he's just got so much
brute strength yeah he can toss a guy
you know further across the room than
you would ever imagine and and those
moments the physics play a little better
but there is kind of an a certain
element of that wire work that adds a
certain fantastical
like the physics of this movie are a
little all over the place i would argue
what's funny to me is that in a lot of
ways
was weird watching in the context of
like watching ben affleck do this role
that made me go
it's like what he did with
like when he did batman it was a redo of
how he could have done daredevil better
you know because there's so he the way
he plays matt burdock is a bad boy he
plays him like a bad boy
you know as i i wasn't even really
comparing him to charlie cox i wasn't
even like thinking about that if
anything just found myself thinking of
like
ben affleck's batman yeah because
actually if i did compare charlie cox
charlie cox brings more of a boyish
sweetness
to the role whereas matt murdock in ben
affleck's is very
short fused and aggressive
and then like oh i'm into this chick
yeah let's play a rough and dirty you
know
chase after her despite her protest oh
my god this cops pissing me off i'm
gonna jack his car i'm gonna like crash
it yeah
yeah
you know like as opposed to like charlie
cox which plays the duality of who he is
as
like that torn tortured
the way how
he has that line in here like i'm not
the bad guy like i feel like with
charlie cox you really get that sense of
struggle
or when that came in here i'm like i
didn't really get the sense of
struggling
no it's just the switch flips of i'm not
gonna let a train cut a guy in half
you killed that guy
you broke his um uh what did he break
and there was his rib cage or something
i forgot he broke there in that moment
oh oh yeah that's who uh
i totally forgot he broke right through
his sternum yeah and then and then he
fell in the train tracks yeah yeah
murdered the guy that bears up
oh boy and uh bullseye if
i
find myself occasionally questioning the
rules which is
strange for me to do in a comic book
movie because i i normally don't when it
comes to anything but the physics i
really i don't ever really like go wait
a minute what but this movie had me
doing that from time to time yeah um
but i i did i did uh i didn't
dislike it i actually thought it was
totally it's above more views for me
that's the new scale
i mean people the way people hype the
director's cut i imagine it must be the
feeling
that people who are not into
snyder's vision of justice league
must
feel like for me i'm like i really think
that zack snyder's justice league movie
is a fantastic film i really believe
that but i know there's people who just
can't and don't don't enjoy it who watch
so they'll watch joss whedon's cut and
go
that's terrible and then they watch zach
snyder's cut and they go
i still don't like it but it's better
even though i don't remember the
theatrical cut
i have a feeling
that's more what my response to this
would be is yeah like uh
it's
fine and like it's not i don't think
it's a terrible film by any means like
there's some questionable stuff and
there's a kind of it's a kind of drag
and get a little bit dull yeah weirdly
it's with the bullseye part when he
comes in where i feel like that's when
the movie should be the most
elevated and exciting
for some reason it just felt like we
were now getting amazing spider-man 2
syndrome [ __ ] where you're just like
you're over introducing too much like
the collector's dad
then die there's there's so many plots
happening here even in your director's
club which is the extended version
even in the extended version which if
i'm not mistaken they did cut out a
whole other plot which was the coolio
thing
so they have you know like when alexa
when elektra's dad dies and then it's oh
it's a lecturer's revenge around it's
like 10 minutes of the movie you know
yeah it's too much there's not enough to
breathe so i didn't feel much when i was
watching this like i felt like kind of
empty
on my experience other than being amused
by certain elements here or there or
appreciating the i think the most
consistent thing i appreciated was the
production design
and uh cinematography and a lot of that
i i like that like
really grainy grimy ugly filming things
to that yeah from the 90s and [ __ ] i
really liked that
um
and i think some of the fighting was
cool and i think ben affleck does a fine
job here i i do
find myself going
this it really did feel like his batman
was a
was a better version of what he was
doing as daredevil for me absolutely
partly my thing i think the thing i i'm
finally starting to put my finger on is
just
i rarely don't see ben affleck when he's
in anything i'm usually like ben affleck
you know and here i was like it's ben
affleck i i like what he's doing i i
think he's charming and and
you know his bad boy take on the role i
am enjoying but i don't really see past
the fact that it's you know
one of hollywood's biggest stars ben
affleck he doesn't do a bad job in it no
not at all not at all i think he does a
pretty good job and i mean he and
jennifer garner have such chemistry yes
it's crazy like i i really was endeared
and i like the romance between them yeah
and that could have felt requisite or
cheesy and it's moments like that like
things like that i wasn't expecting like
that moment on the rooftop where we were
at first laughing about it being kind of
cheesy like when it starts to rain and
you see
the the vision he described like it's
like i can see you for the first time
like that actually touched me and i was
like that's kind of beautiful actually
like that's a nuance i hadn't expected
from this movie and i feel like part of
what
uh starts to drag and undercut
characters like
funny enough i came in expecting
everyone had always told me that
bullseye and kingpin are the best parts
and i watched this and the thing that
kind of hampers those two for me is that
you know you're so one note well yeah
there's just nothing to those characters
except the immediate moment of them
being maniacal and so they give you
stuff to kind of latch onto or they
characterize everybody else and they
don't characterize them beyond what the
actors are doing right now so especially
when uh when bullseye keeps showing up
it's like you're literally just cutting
to a different rock music video for a
couple seconds while he does some cool
thing says a lot like a badass quip and
then touches his head and it's like you
know you're you're pumping in like a
matrix music video and then cutting back
to a real movie yeah periodically and so
yeah there is like a weird disjointed
quality that they bring that if you're
not like 100 with it does kind of drag
or or does kind of leave you looking at
the periphery and thinking about the
construction or things that you
shouldn't be thinking about when you
should be just pulled into
you know what's going on
yeah it's a silly phone is it
i
i i don't know i'm so conflicted about
it because i think i like the first 40
minutes more than anything else
absolutely i agree i think the first 40
minutes are striking the right balance
of you're taking yourself
really serious but then you're
you're
you know like you're sometimes you're so
fun you're so cheesy that uh like i love
it i just love that some of the some of
the dialogue is so bad sometimes that
just cracks me up and i'm like i don't
mind it it's funny and um but sometimes
the violence really does hit i'm like oh
my god
that's violent yeah you know yeah in a
way that's not overly grotesque but it
still hits yeah yeah i think that's like
pretty impressive and how they did that
i like the first fight a lot with
daredevil and the people in the bar
mm-hmm
um i like him and john favreau together
yeah you know john favreau's fully john
forever that's doing the job fam
birthday
i liked him like there's not much
difference between here and happy
he's just dropped fabric and the fur
that's good is good daredevil didn't get
to that point because he would just be
he's happy with this franchise after a
while yeah like i like that and i do
agree on the the column feral parts were
depending on the scene at times very
amusing what he was doing
but in an isolated sense i enjoyed him a
lot and uh in the church
fight
like just how because he gets a few
misses he just like panics he's like
freaks out like my world is shattering
my whole my whole identity is based off
of never missing he just like freaks out
and he pants like a dog like literally i
i feel like if i watch an interview with
him he'd be like i based my performance
off a bulldog yeah i know i think that's
a good call like because he really does
have that sort of like one track mind
this like weird spunky energy like let
me add him let me add them yeah yeah it
definitely feels like a cartoon dog
yeah it's it's uh it's it's it's
fascinating and i do think the
yeah they had like more heart and a good
a better flow but i think the
i feel like there are things about the
kingpin performance that i i don't know
no disrespect to michael clark duncan
who i think is a wonderful actor
and i i feel like he did what the script
would want him to do
i
i just had a hard time getting on board
with it for some reason like it never
struck me as menacing just goofy i was
never afraid i feel like we really
should have had at least one moment to
br he kind of reminded me of a very
subdued version of tommy lee jones's
two-face and i feel like if we have had
a moment to really see all of that
garish personality
fade away because even when he's
fighting daredevil at the end like
there's there's laughing and there's
sort of his energy carries through that
and if we could see one instance of not
one of his goons taking care of
something but of him doing something
totally terrible
and deplorable i feel like that would
have helped a lot taking something
intensely serious and being threatening
as opposed to just always
it's like that
annoying go-to bad guy thing for me like
let's just really
he's just loving the smile and laughs
always loving this
yeah where i'm like i might have been
more interested if you were if you
played it offended by
him wanting to back out mm-hmm you know
as opposed to
how's your daughter yeah
i was hoping you'd say yeah oh my god
someone's just all right
threat the threats are so over the top
yeah i like joe pantaliano a lot too
yeah he's great he's still alive i
forgot dude he passed away i break i
don't forget i feel like i haven't seen
him forever i haven't seen him in a
while but i think he's i think he's
still with us i hope so um but i think
he's great i think i mean he's great in
like literally anything he does he's
he's always great
um
two actors in the sopranos were here and
yeah he was he was great in here and i
really liked the presence that he
brought for ben urich and like he feels
like a real
i really believe that he would go
through publishing the article yeah yeah
i got that but i also believe that he
would delete the article exactly like
that's a really good character for trail
i think that played really nice and
that's and that's well within the the
tone here it's it's funny it's like i
feel like this is probably a much more
consistent movie than the theatrical cut
is i feel like it's still at odds with
yeah the more bouncy fun aspects and the
more you know dark gothic aspects and i
feel like most issues you could have
with this movie sort of boil down to if
they just proportioned those things a
bit better together but he is a
character who has a through line fits
very naturally with everything and i
think ben affleck does a really good job
in the more
despairing moments of his performance
when he's feeling really hollow i think
that he does a really good job in those
those key sequences
you know um actually i think he's like
really good he's never had a moment
where i was like that's about acting you
know i never i never had anything like
that
uh i just yeah i i did have the
i never i did i was always aware it was
ben affleck yeah i was always like ben
affleck's doing a good job yeah you know
he's watching ben affleck yeah
absolutely and hey he must have he must
have been the guy who brought kevin
smith in
true true yeah that's a fun cameo yeah
i'm a bad actor like kevin smith but
overall
yeah
it's the same morpheus because my my
reaction to when it's all said and done
is
it was fine it does get a little boring
in the middle honestly because that you
just i just don't care about any of the
actual drama like the yeah the drama is
not gripping and i i honestly while i
appreciate the execution of the lawyer
stuff and i think coolio brings a lot of
fun to it uh
i did find it unnecessary like
ultimately to the point that if it is
cut out like i like the concept of you
actually get to see matt murdock do
lawyer [ __ ]
versus in the theatrical cut i imagine
you don't really see him gonna do any of
that so i do appreciate that you get to
see that i just
i wasn't that interested in it and so
the with a movie that is not as
consistent with its tone it gets really
bogged down in a lot of drama that
i don't really care about
so it was most entertaining to me
when there was you know actual [ __ ]
happening here that was like look at
them fight yeah you know
they're running around i'm building tops
yeah look at them have an argument
that's actually engaging or something
like that but i'm not rooting for
i'm not rooting for matt murdock in this
firm i'm not rooting for the firm of of
of foggy and nelson
uh i'm not really rooting for anything
to be totally honest
i don't really want ben affleck i'm like
oh yeah that's right kingpin killed your
dad like yeah i'm not it's easy i'm not
rooting for him to get revenge and i'm
not rooting for a lecture to get revenge
i'm not
there's nothing that this movie makes me
look forward to or that i'm fascinated
by or that i'm rooting for i'm just
sort of
amused
through most of it yeah it was a fun
pleasant watch and i feel like the most
impact i got was out of more of the
technical aspects of just being like wow
this this holds up surprisingly yeah
there's some cool technical production
yeah like i think that but that wears
off like you get used to it and where it
it wears thin after a while uh to to the
point where what's the word i often hear
with like michael bay
movies
when you get used to
the explosions and all that there's this
this is sort of toes
or something there's an actual phrase
that i hear all the time with the
michael bay film
that if
they obey him
and something no just something about
yeah that would be numbing
the point that it's communicating is
that like after a while you you are just
completely unaffected by it and it
becomes boring like sensory overload
uh that's not quite it no not your
overload
it's not overwhelming it's just
that
appreciation that has that elicits an
emotional response from me
starts to wear off yeah and i stopped
being like oh but that is so cool to
look at and you know it's actually
pretty neat for me and that it was
really in the first half hour when i
would see certain shots i'm like that's
pretty
you don't see that in comic book movies
and to be to this movie's credit you
don't get like this is more bold than
[ __ ] anything sony's been doing with
their dark marvel sony characters
spider-man or whatever the hell it's
called like this is more bold than any
of that the way they went here i think
is this
the next step for the sony spider-man
universe of its dark characters should
aspire to be more like the daredevil's
director's got this this is more of what
they ought to be like
and
i don't think this movie was then again
i don't really i don't remember the
theatrical cut so
but going off of this i'm like this is
not a terrible film and i can see why
people really like it but the people i
see that really love it i i rarely
encounter the individual who's like i've
never seen a theatrical one i'm only
saying director's cut uh
but i think that if you watch it the
actual and then this one you're like
this is so much better because because
you saw that one you know yeah you have
the point of comparison like for me yeah
this is my first experience be on the
trailers and that promo they always used
to run to theaters about the
choreography of the fights of this movie
chong yen yoon we call him the master uh
but yeah like this
isn't like a movie i love
based off of this i'm like i'm glad i
saw it i would watch it again sometime
if someone really wanted to but i do
agree that this has
that dark unit that dark sony
spider-verse quality that i
feel much better than them it is it is i
would break this book it's a real movie
it's like yeah it's more consistent and
it's more thought out it feels like and
it feels like it though it feels like
visually striking a lot of the time and
it seems like purposeful and how they
did it
yeah and and the camp and the pulp that
arises from that often feels like it
still kind of fits instead of enjoying
it despite itself they had a lot of like
composition to the way they were framing
this movie
like this movie didn't feel like let's
figure this out in editing like it feels
like they mapped it out in storyboarded
scenes and how they were gonna visually
graph this film together like it feels
intentional and purposeful whereas a lot
of these other ones feel like
like nowadays they just feel like a mess
yeah you know and this doesn't this does
not feel like a mess to me
it just
falls a little flat for me yeah it'll be
more dynamic and it could be better
fleshed in certain aspects
yeah
yeah and i'm like even in the theatrical
like there's some things you just have
to cut
it's like
something needed to be just written out
before filming is the thing it wouldn't
be like you could have fixed this and
like there's not a version where you can
fix this
final product in editing and by trimming
some other stuff out i would be like no
you would have to start with the
screenplay and change some of that up
before filming the damn thing because
yeah there are things that definitely
did not
wait uh hit as strong as they could have
like those emotional beats are not hit
that strong
but
hey glad i watched it finally
you've been counted for years to watch
this film
uh thanks for being here subscribe click
that bell and hey let's uh do a patreon
scooba steve the devil scuba diving
devil of hell's kitchen out there in
switzer sweden tagging all the swiss
walls with your
prime prime with your painted
scuba crab but what you're really doing
is covering wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait what are you talking
about steve scuba esteban i was thinking
of the other guy michael linden oh we
could do michael we could switch let me
go with scuba scuba hey whether it's
switzerland freaking rhode island or
okay whether hey hell's kitchen
switzerland rhode island sweden wherever
you happen to be all right thug cooper
you're the sprayer who's spray paints
yeah he's just every single movie that's
also the one obsessed with horror and
there's always amazing yeah i remember
scuba yeah he's always tagging stuff
that looks like a horror movie or
something like that i know now we can do
the shadow true horror is crying yeah
scuba thanks man thanks dog
thanks for raiders love you buddy hope
you're doing well man send us some more
obscure horror recommendations you're a
fantastic individual
terrible job if he only stopped
interrupting me you know i would have
been able to nail that take it away
[Music]
you